we have long been fascinated by cults
but seldom get to see inside their world
which in april of 2007 National
Geographic Channel was granted access to
the strong city cult and its leader
Michael traverser
who claims to be the Messiah I am the
embodiment of God divinity and humanity
combined Michael has opened the gates of
strong city let the world share the Word
of God he has told his followers that
the world will soon end that he is their
only route to heaven but who joins a
cult like this and how do the members
live for God to bring a plague other
Masonic cult leaders have predicted the
end and guaranteed salvation but could
the pursuit of heaven go horribly wrong
as it has for some other cults in
American history
and his strong City just a pretext for
more earthly desires I took off my
clothes and I laid naked on his bed and
he just held me and it was like a whole
new picture opened up to me of God but
31 people have left since Michael
claimed to be the Son of God and some ex
members have alleged on the internet
that in 2006 Michael lay naked on his
bed with a number of the cults girls
among those mentioned Esther and
Danielle I don't know it was probably in
the beginning part of July Michael wrote
a post about how the only way to kind of
like come to resolution in your life is
to be naked before God mm-hmm we just
puzzled me you know and but it was like
something was in me and what was in me
was this means really this means
literally physically naked and it was in
me that it meant with Michael so so he
he took me to it to the bedroom and laid
down and he held me somehow it was like
all of heaven was open to me somehow I
started to see God well somehow as an
ex-member prudence Welch knows the
effect of Michael's words her internet
site publishes messages Michael has sent
to his followers
she says he uses the power of suggestion
to plant thoughts in their minds
thoughts they then believer their own
for prudence it's nothing more than
simple manipulation and so he started
writing about being naked you have to be
with me naked and unashamed so then
pretty soon they're getting the picture
and they're all begging to lay naked
with him and then it's like well I'm not
the one that asked for that they're the
ones begging me for it they're the ones
that wants to consummate with me I
didn't do you know I didn't do anything
to want that you know so it's like
that's how he has controlled them but
it's not unusual for a call
to engage in sexual relations even those
who claim divinity
well sex is one of the very common
control mechanisms used in cultic groups
if you're able to control someone's
sexuality or their sexual behavior
that's reaching into the deepest part of
that person I mean and that's also
touching what for many people is not
only the most intimate part of
themselves but the place where people
are often troubled or questioning or
unsure of themselves after Esther and
Danielle laid naked with Michael he said
God needed seven virgins for a ceremony
to mark the forthcoming destruction of
the earth over the next few days five
more virgins came to Michael to lie
naked - were underage but Michael
insists the Virgin's actions were
instructions from heaven well it was God
God came down on them and told him to do
it
nakedness is another symbol of our
relationship with God we are naked and
unashamed